So let,
let,
let me ask you,
um,
the rules you have are not based in US law,
right?
US law doesn't recognize restrictions on hate speech.
It's considered free speech.
So if you want to stand on a street corner and yell the craziest things in the
world,
you're allowed to on your platform,
Twitter,
you're not allowed to.
So even in that sense alone,
your rules do have an ideology behind them.
I don't completely disagree.
I think,
you know,
I don't want harassment.
Um,
but the reason I bring this up is getting into the discussion about democratic
health of a nation.
So I think it's,
it can't be disputed at this point that Twitter is extremely powerful in
influencing elections.
You know,
I,
I'm pretty sure you guys published recently a bunch of tweets from foreign
actors that were trying to mettle in elections.
So even you as a company recognize that foreign entities are trying to
manipulate people using this platform.
So I,
I,
there's a few things I want to ask beyond this,
but if wouldn't it be important then to just as a,
at a certain point,
Twitter becomes so powerful in influencing elections and giving access to even
the president's tweets that you should allow people to use the platform based
under the norms of US law,
First Amendment,
free speech,
the right to expression on the platform.
This is becoming too much,
uh,
of uh,
it's becoming too powerful and how our elections are,
are taking place.
So even if you are saying,
well,
hate speeches,
our role in a lot of people agree with that.
If at any 0.1 person disagrees,
they're still an American who has a right to this,
you know,
to access to the public discourse and you've essentially monopolize that and not
completely,
but for the most part.
So isn't there some responsibility on you to guarantee at at a certain extent,
less regulation happen,
right?
Like,
look,
if you,
if you recognize foreign governments are manipulating our elections,
then shouldn't you guarantee the right to an American to access this platform to
be involved in the electoral process?
I'm not sure I see the,
the,
the tie between those things,
but I will address one of your points,
which was,
uh,
we're not,
we're a platform that serves the world.
So we're a global,
uh,
75% of the users of Twitter or outside of the United States.
Oh,
right,
right.
So we don't,
uh,
apply laws of Jess one country when we're thinking about it and we think about,
um,
how do you have a global standard that can meet the threshold of as many
countries as possible because we want all the people in the world to be able to
participate in this conversation.
Some elections like the Indian election coming up as well.
Right.
And I'm,
I'm,
I,
my understanding is you were also accused of being biased against conservatives
in India recently.
There was a report on that as well as you held up a sign that said something
offensive about the Brahman [inaudible].
Yeah.
So in that sense,
even in other countries,
you're accused of the same things that you're being accused of by American
conservatives.
Okay.
I think there,
those situations are very,
very different.
Um,
and I don't think that that the ideologies in play are the same at all.
Well,
so the,
the reason everyone,
can we clarify that?
[inaudible] I,
I'm not sure what you're talking about,
but we did have our vice president public policy testified in front of Indian
parliament a couple of weeks ago and he was,
they were really focused on election integrity and safety and abuse,
harassment
of women in political figures in the likes.
So,
so my,
my,
my concern I guess is I recognize your globe.
You're a company that serves the world,
but as an American I have a concern that the democracy I live in the Democratic
Republic,
I'm sorry,
in the democratic functions are healthy.
One of the biggest threats is,
you know,
Russia,
Iran,
China,
they're trying to meddle in our elections using your platform.
And it's effective.
So much so that you've actually come out and removed money.
People,
you know,
Covington was apparently started by account base in Brazil.
You know,
the Covington scandal where this fake news goes viral was reported by CNN.
That was,
it was a dummy account.
They were trying to prop it up and they were pushing out this out of context
information.
So they do this,
they use your platform to do it.
You've now got a platform that is so powerful in our American discourse that
foreign governments are using it as weapons against us.
And you've taken a stance against the laws of the United States.
I don't mean like against like you're breaking the law.
I mean you,
you have rules that go beyond the scope of the u s which will restrict American
citizens from being able to participate.
Meanwhile,
foreign actors are free to do so,
so long as they play by your rules.
So our elections are being threatened by the fact that if there's an American
citizen who says,
I do not believe in your mis-gendering policy,
and you bend them,
that person has been removed from public discourse on Twitter.
Right?
But they don't get banned for saying they don't agree with it.
Getting him for sure specifically violating it by targeting an individual,
let's say in protest and individual repeatedly says,
no,
I refuse to use your pronouns in like Megan Murphy's case.
And she's Canadian,
so I don't want to use her specifically.
The point I'm trying to make is at a certain level,
there are going to be American citizens who have been removed from this public
discourse,
which has become so absurdly powerful.
Foreign governments weaponize it because you have different rules than the
American country has.
Just to be clear,
my understanding,
and I'm not expert on all the platforms,
is that foreign governments use multiple,
multiple different ways to interfere in elections and not limited to our
platform,
nor is that limited to social media.
But the president design Twitter,
right president is on a lot of different platforms as is the White House.
Uh,
I think it's fair to point out the media coverage of his Twitter account is
insane and they run a new stories every time he tweets and certainly undeniable.
I'm just pointing out that there are a number of different avenues and
individuals have choices and how they use the platform so that you'd have other
platforms,
but he uses Twitter exclusively.
And what I'm trying to bring up is that if Twitter refuses to acknowledge this
problem,
you are facing regulation.
I don't,
I don't know if you care about that,
but at a certain point,
which problem,
if you're going to restrict American citizens from participating on a platform
or even the president speaks and it's essentially you have a private,
privately owned public space,
as if I could use an analogy that would be most apt and you've set rules that
are not recognized by the u s in fact,
when it came to a supreme court hearing,
they said,
hate speech is not a violation.
It's actually protected free speech.
So there's an actual odds.
So there might be someone who says,
I refuse to live by any other means than,
uh,
what the Supreme Court sat down.
That means I have a right to hate speech.
You will bend them.
That means your platform is so powerful.
It's,
it's being used to manipulate elections and you have rules that are not
recognized by the government to remove American citizens from that discourse.
So as a private platform,
you've become too powerful to not be regulated if you refuse to allow people
free speech.
But,
um,
I'm trying to pick apart,
the connection.
I think so,
yes,
we,
we do have an issue with,
um,
foreign entities and misinformation and,
and this is a extremely complicated issue,
which we're just beginning to understand and grasp and take action on.
I,
I don't think that issue is solved purely by not being more aggressive on
something else that is taking people off the platform entirely as well,
which is abuse and harassment.
It's a cost benefit analysis ultimately in our rules are designed again and you
know,
they don't always manifest this way in the outcomes,
but in terms of what we're trying to drive is opportunity for every single
person to be able to speak freely on the platform.
That's absolutely not true.
You would done a lightspeed allow hate speech.
So free speech is not on your platform.
I said,
speak for enable everyone that create the opportunity for everyone to speak on
our service unless they've all right.
And then in part of that,
the recognition that we're taking action on is that when some people encounter
particular conduct that we see them wanting to remove themselves from the
platform completely,
which goes against that principle of enabling everyone to speak or giving people
the opportunity to speak.
Our rules are focused on the the opportunities presented and we have particular
outcomes to make sure that those opportunities are
soldier as possible.
Let's,
let's separate the first I,
the point I made about foreign governments was just to explain the,
the,
the power that your platform holds.
How can be weaponized?
We'll separate that now.
When antifa shows up to Berkeley and bashes a guy over there with a bike lock
that is suppressing his speech,
right?
That's an act of physical violence.
However,
when Auntie fall links hands and blocks the door so that no one can go to an
event that is also legally allowed,
right?
So what you're saying is that if someone is engaging in behavior such as going
on Twitter and shouting someone down relentlessly,
that's something external to what happens in,
in,
in the world under the u s government.
I am allowed to scream very close to you and not let you speak in public,
but on Twitter you don't allow that.
So there's a dramatic difference between what Twitter thinks is okay and what
the u s government thinks is okay.
Our democracy functions and how Twitter functions.
The issue I'm pointing out is that we know Twitter is becoming extremely
important in how our public discourse is occurring,
how our cultural culture is developing and who even gets elected.
So if you have rules that are based on a global policy,
that means American citizens who are abiding by all of the laws of our country
are being restricted from engaging in public discourse because you've
monopolized it.
Can I counter that though?
Because these foreign governments are restricted by the same rules.
So if they violate those same rules,
they will be,
they will be removed.
So play within those rules.
They can participate in the discourse even if they are just trying to manipulate
our elections.
On the other hand,
if the people that are on the platform play by those rules,
they can also counteract unless their ideology goes in line with us.
Law and it's legally allowed as opposed to what you allow.
So foreign governments can can absolutely keep making new accounts and keep
bottling and keep manipulating.
They can even post things that'll go viral and then get banned and not care.
Right.
But a private American citizen can say,
here's my opinion,
I refuse to back down.
I see what you're saying.
You will ban him.
So we can see that at a certain point you have a lot your,
your,
your Twitter is slowly gaining in,
in my opinion,
too much control from your personal ideology based on what you've researched,
what you think is right over American discourse.
If you,
if Twitter,
and this again is my opinion,
I'm not a lawmaker,
but I would have to assume if Twitter refuses to say in the United States you
are allowed to say what is legally acceptable period.
Then lawmakers only choice will be to enforce regulation on your company.
Actually tell him,
I spent quite a bit of time talking to lawmakers as part of my role,
had a public policy.
Um,
I spent a lot of time in DC.
I want to say the Jack and I have both spent a lot of time in DC and I think
from the perspective of of lawmakers,
they across the spectrum are also in favor of policing,
abuse and harassment online and bullying online.
Those are things that people care about because they affect their children if
they affect their communities and they fact individuals.
And so I don't think that,
and as a,
as a private American business,
we can have different standards than what an American government owned
corporations or American government would have to institute.
Those are two different things,
American bit.
And I understand your point about the influence and I'm not denying that.
Certainly Twitter is an influential platform,
but like anything,
whether it's the American law or the rules of Twitter or the rules of Facebook
or wills of any platform,
there are rules and those rules have to be followed.
So it is your choice whether to follow those rules and to continue to
participate in a civic dialogue.
And it's your choice to not do that.
Absolutely.
You've monopolized public discourse to an extreme degree and you say my way or
the highway
we are facing Tim,
we haven't monopolize it.
There are many different avenues for people to continue to have a voice.
There are many different platforms that offer that we are a largely influential
line.
I'm not trying to take away from that and we're a very important one.
You don't need to be the most important.
It's just that you are extremely important and that's,
and it's a compliment.
Twitter has become extremely powerful,
but at a certain point you should not have the right to control what people are
allowed to say.
No private or outlook.
I'm a social liberal.
I think we should regulate you guys because you are unelected officials running
your system the way you see fit against the wishes of a democratic republic.
And there are who disagree with you or being excised from public discourse
because of your ideology.
That terrifies me.
And we can take it one step further just so I understand.
So are you suggesting that we don't have any policies around abuse and
harassment on the platform?
Um,
I'm trying to understand what it is you're saying cause I'm not,
I'm not sure I'm following you.
So you don't think we should have any rules about abuse and harassment.
So even though the threats that you received that you mentioned that we did,
but you mentioned a number of threats that you received in your quite frustrated
that we hadn't taken action on them,
that you think we shouldn't have roles.
That I'm frustrated because of the hypocrisy.
When I,
when I see,
I see the flow of one direction and then what I see are Republican politicians
who in my opinion are just too ignorant to understand what the hell's going on
around them.
And I see people burning signs that say free speech Icu openly saying we
recognize the power of our platform and we're not going to abide by American
norms.
I see the manipulation of Twitter for uh,
in violation of our elections.
I see democratic operatives in Alabama waging a false flag campaign using fake
Russian accounts and the,
and the,
and the guy who runs that company has not been banned from your platform even
after it's been written by the New York Times.
He was doing this.
So we know that not only are people manipulating your platform,
you have rules that remove honest American citizens with bad opinions who have a
right to engage in public discourse.
And it's like you recognize it but you like having the power.
I'm not quite sure at what point,
get back to my point.
So you believe that Twitter should not have any rules about abuse and harassment
or any sort of hate speech on the platform that that's your position.
That's a extremely productive,
I don't know that maybe,
maybe too simplistic.
The point I'm trying to make is,
but that would have you ain't,
you're trying to make your,
you're asking us to comply with the u s law that would criminalize potential
speech and put people in jail for it.
And you're asking us to enforce those,
those while,
I mean,
if you insight death,
you will,
it's a crime.
You can go,
you can go to jail for that.
So at the very least,
you could,
you like when you,
when you have people on your platform who committed a crime,
you don't ban them.
I say,
well,
that's really weird.
And then when you have people on your platform who say a bad,
naughty word.